camille et elena se sont rencontrés il
ya quelques mois sur le réseau social
instagram toutes les deux passionnés de
créations artisanales
elles ont pris l'habitude de travailler
ensemble pour attendre la chasse aux
oeufs un trophée lapin de pâques
première étape avec elena le lapin en
poupe je vais faire l'arrière de la tête
de notre petit lapin donc c'est très
simple l'arrière de la tête qui les unit
je me contente de bien fixer la matrice
de façon à ce que des deux moitiés soit
bien que les mêmes contre l'autre je
bloque mon fils et je commence à tourner
pour couvrir avec de la laine de couleur
différente
pouvait on su créer les éléments du
visage en prenant garde à bien respecter
la symétrie ont rajouté quelques tours
assez lâches pour faire les oreilles sur
la partie supérieure du complot vient
ensuite le découpage l'on découvre enfin
la phase de son poupon
donc maintenant on va sculpter le
lapointe pour les oreilles elena utile
et des aiguilles est feutrée qui vont
venir mélanger les fibres de la laine et
lui donner une autre texture les yeux
même chose vous pouvez vous servir de
l'aiguillât faudrait pour enfoncer les
poils des yeux et dans les sept
solitaires plus naturel quand voulant
prendre
de son côté camille ses talents en
couture et crochet s'occupe de la partie
textile elle commence par fabriquer un
noeud en découpant 3 rectangle de tissu
de tailles différentes
un pliage précis pour former des tubes
c'est ensuite les assembler pour
constituer notre nom aux tissus et là on
va juste fermé par quelques points à la
main le petit tube à l'arrière d'une
partie la plus technique le cadran en
crochet pour cela qu'elle va venir
couvrir un cerceau métallique avec trois
méthodes de crochets différentes
l'émail série doivent être par multiple
de 6 et le serviront de base pour les
deux autres tours cette étape minutieuse
et la plus longue
reste ensuite le fond l'étape la plus
simple et la plus rapide
on va venir prendre une feutrine épaisse
quelque chose qui a un petit peu de un
petit peu de tenue sur lequel on va
venir coller un cercle de tissus qu'on
aura des coupes et à la montagne
ne reste plus qu'à coups en fond et
cadres en avant de procéder à
l'assemblage final votre trophée lapin
de pâques est fin prêt pour venir
décorer la chambre de votre enfant
si vous n'êtes pas aussi doué que nos
deux créatrices vous pouvez toujours les
contacts et sur leur compte instagram et
passer commande